what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard videos where I cover
solutions to today's problems in society
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
video on your way in let's get started
so today I wanted to talk about
society's biggest problem ever now I I
want to tell you guys this problem is so
big that it causes everything wrong with
Society okay so I'm gonna write this on
the way
non-virgin women cause all of the
world's problems now before you shoot
the messenger let me just explain to you
why that is there's been different
studies that show that when a woman
sleeps around she is less likely to stay
married and be happily married so
essentially when a woman
you know let's just put some guys here
so when a woman has sex with a bunch of
dudes what happens next is she can't
really bond anymore so one day she gets
married and boom she's sad married
because she misses the guys over here
some guy maybe this one was her favorite
she says Ah I'm stuck with Bob I wish I
had chat now the issue is you know women
used to just be unhappy and deal with it
but now we have a society where they say
your happiness is so important and even
when she's in a marriage these are like
Timmy and Bobby right there she says I'm
sad I want to be happy so she's actually
given money to leave him so she gets
child support alimony whatever she says
I am gonna leave my man I don't care
about my kids all because I was a
before and slept with these dudes and
mine is you guys the data shows that the
biggest drop in marital happiness is
actually going from one guy to human you
know a woman and it's there's different
studies that it's slightly different but
overall a woman that's a virgin on her
wedding day has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage when it gets to two guys it
drops to 50 now not only is this woman
paid to take his money she's also paid
to falsely accuse him of abuse and take
his kids away for a lifetime so she's
over there she's got Timmy and Turner
now what does this what does this lead
to so I want to list out a couple things
that seem to be caused by single mother
home
the majority of the homeless are from
single mother home the majority of
criminals are from single mother homes
the majority of School shooters are from
single mother home the majority of
people with mental problems are from
single mother homes the majority of teen
runaways are from single mother home and
this is why we used to have institutions
social shame and safeguards to protect
women from ourselves because when the
women are it ruins Society now
they're saying one out of every three
kids will be alienated from their father
within the first three years of life now
mind you when men raise children it is
not the same they raise better kids so
we have two solutions here they always
say pearl what's your Solutions well
today baby I'm going through them one
men should only marry virgins or men
automatically get custody because crazy
women that leave marriages should not be
rewarded and we get rid of the money
that pays women to leave and just tell
them to work it out like the boss
you are let me know what you guys think
in the comments let me know your
solutions for society like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time
[Music]